I know what my father was what he did I
know the Mad King earned his name kill
every Targaryen get my answer
everyone who wasn't
is an enemy
so is it bring me his head what's up
ladies and gentlemen welcome back for
another game of thorns update video
today I want to further discuss the new
series HBO is currently working on HBO
did announce that they ordered a new
pilot for a prequels show - Game of
Thrones in this new series will take
place during the Age of Heroes there
isn't a ton of information about this
time period but I want to go over some
of that information that is in the books
then hopefully we can get a better sense
of what type of show we can expect to
see when I first saw the headline that
HT I wanted to make a series about the
Age of Heroes my first thought was well
that is kind of vague because the Age of
Heroes lasted for thousands of years but
if you look at this statement they
released it does narrow it down a little
bit let's take a look at HBO statement
then we can start discussing what I
think this show will most likely cover
so far all HBO has said about this new
pilot is it will be taking place
thousands of years before the events of
Game of Thrones the series chronicles
the world's descent from the Golden Age
of Heroes into its darkest hour and only
one thing is for sure from the
horrifying secrets of Westeros is
history - the true origin of the White
Walkers the mysteries of the east to the
Starks of legend it's not the story we
think we know it definitely sounds like
at least a portion of this show will
take place during the long night but
what we think we know about the long
night might not actually be true even
the origins of the White Walkers might
not be true according to the version we
got in Game of Thrones but before I go
down that road let me go over some of
the basic details about the Age of
Heroes like I said earlier the Age of
Heroes lasted for thousands of years in
which kingdoms rose and fell noble
houses were founded in weathered away
and great deeds were accomplished yet
what we truly know of those ancient days
is hardly more than what we know of the
dawn age the tales we have now are the
work of septons and maesters writing
thousands of years after the fact
yet unlike the children of the forest
and the Giants the first men of this age
of Heroes left behind some ruins and
ancient castles that can corroborate
parts of the legends and there are stone
monuments in the bara fields and
elsewhere marked with their rooms it is
through these remnants that we can begin
to ferret out the truth behind these
tales what is commonly accepted is that
the Age of Heroes began with the pact
and extended through the thousands of
years in which the first men and the
children lived in peace with one another
now for those of you who aren't very
familiar with the timeline I will go
over some of the things that we have
been told since the new series is going
so far back in time you're gonna need to
know some of these things in order to
give context to what we might see take a
look at the timeline on the screen and
look all the way to your left
13,000 years ago Westeros was inhabited
by the children of the forest and they
weren't just living beyond the wall in a
cave at this time they basically had
free reign over the continent that was
until the first men arrived about 12,000
years ago and this was known as the dawn
age the first men came from Essos which
is where the legend of azor Ahai comes
from when the first men showed up in
Westeros all hell broke loose they
started to move in on the children of
the forest and the first men starting
cutting down everything in sight
including the children's sacred weirwood
trees this is when the children of the
forest really started to fight back the
children's weapons and armor were [ __ ]
compared to what the first men had at
the time the children actually had armor
made out of tree bark while the first
men had an armor made out of bronze so
you can only imagine how brutal these
battles must have been it had gotten so
bad that the children thought they were
going to go extinct but they are very
resilient creatures who knew their woods
better than the men who came to cut them
down not only did the children have
home-field advantage but they also knew
magic what should the first men knew
nothing of these conflicts lasted for
another 2,000 years until they made the
pact on what is now known as the Isle of
faces after 2,000 years of bloodshed the
two sides finally
to bring their fighting to an end both
groups came together on an island in the
middle of a great lake in central
Westeros known as the gods I there they
forged a lasting peace known as the pact
the open lands were granted to humanity
while the deep forests were to remain
the undisturbed domain of the children
the first men were forbidden from ever
cutting down a sacred weirwood tree
again and to commemorate the pact the
children of the forest carved a face
into every weirwood tree on the island
making each a hard tree and thereafter
the island has been known as the Isle of
faces after they made their pact this is
when the Age of Heroes begins things
were relatively peaceful at this time
but after another 2,000 years pass this
is when all hell breaks loose again
during what is known as the long night
as the first men established their
realms following the pact little
troubled them save their own feuds and
wars or so the histories tell us it is
also from these histories that we learn
of the long night when a season of
winter came that lasted a generation a
generation in which children were born
grew into adulthood and in many cases
died without ever seeing the spring
indeed some of the old wives tales say
that they never even beheld the light of
day so complete was the winter that fell
on the world while this last may well be
no more than fancy the fact that some
Cataclysm took place many thousands of
years ago seemed certain in this time
night seems to last for a generation and
the longest coldest and darkest winter
descends on Westeros the ice spreads
down from the far north and under the
cover of darkness the others invade
Westeros from the uttermost north
marching killing and raising up the dead
to be their servants and nearly
destroying all men in Westeros however
the long night comes to an end with the
battle for the dawn the children and the
first men unite to defeat the others
with dragonglass weapons and what the
Nights Watch pushing them back into the
frozen reaches of the far
legendary figures from this time include
the last hero and azor Ahai who forged a
red sword of heroes known as light
bringer we have heard of the last hero
from one of old names tales during the
long night he set out into the Deadlands
with a sword a horse a dog and a dozen
companions for years he searched until
he despaired of ever finding the
children of the forest in their secret
cities one by one his friends died and
his horse and finally even his dog and
his sword froze so hard the blade
snapped when he tried to use it and the
others smelled the hot blood in him and
came silent on his trail stalking him
with packs of pale white spiders big as
hounds and we have heard of azor Ahai
from Melisandre and even Salladhor
saying in the books Azure 'hi is a
legendary figure in the faith over lore
also known as the Lord of Light
thousands of years ago he forged the
sword Lightbringer which he used to
defeat the darkness of the great other
now the problem with legends like these
are we don't even know if they are true
it could also be possible that the last
hero and Ozora high are the same person
I am hoping some of these questions get
answered what the new series HBO is
doing because in their statement they
did say only one thing is for sure from
the horrifying secrets of Westeros is
history to the true origin of the White
Walkers the mysteries of the east to the
Starks of legend it's not the story we
think we know everything we've been told
could be a lie including what happened
directly after the long night ended one
thing I am hoping this new series will
cover is how the White Walkers were
actually stopped during the long night
they says one part of the story that is
left open for interpretation but I need
to know the facts is the story about the
last hero in Essaouira hide just another
bedtime story or were these legendary
figures real people if they were then I
need to know exactly how they were able
to get the White Walkers to go back to
the lands of always winter were the
others scared of one of these legendary
characters or did they make some kind of
a peace treaty all we've really been
told is the others were pushed back into
the north
and this is when the wall was built and
the Nights Watch was established this is
back when the children of the forest
used to give the Knights watch a hundred
daggers of obsidian every year these are
a few of the other interesting things of
this new show may cover HBO statement
does mention the true origin of the
White Walkers but we can also get the
origin story of the Nights Watch
they are the sworn Brotherhood that has
defended the wall of her centuries and
millennia born in the aftermath of the
long night the history of the Nights
Watch is a long one and the same thing
goes for the wall itself legend has it
that the Giants helped raise the wall
using their great strength to wrestle
the blocks of ice into place there may
be some truth to this though the stories
make the Giants out to be far larger and
more powerful than they truly were these
same legends also say that the children
of the forest would contribute their
magic to the construction of the wall
but all of these legends should be taken
with a grain of salt whether the legends
are true or not it is plain that the
first men and the chosen or the forest
along with the Giants must have feared
something enough that it drove them to
begin raising the wall history tells us
that this is how the wall was built but
can we trust it we know the others can
manipulate the ice with their own magic
so how do we know it wasn't the others
who actually built the wall beneath the
shadow of that wall of ice the Nights
Watch raised 19 strongholds the greatest
and oldest of these is the knight for
which has been abandoned for the past
200 years the Nightfort has many legends
of its own in the oldest of these tales
concerned the legendary Knights King the
thirteenth Lord Commander of the Nights
Watch no one knows anything about the
first 12 Lord commanders that come
before him and the true story behind
that could be an interesting story of
its own we don't know the names of the
first 12 Lord commanders of the Nights
Watch but I have always wondered if it
has something to do with the last heroes
12 companions that either went missing
or died depending on how many years this
new show will cover we may find out more
about the original Knights King that
ruled the wall from the Nightfort for 13
years with his corpse queen who was also
known as the Knights Queen I've always
been fast
needed by this story because it ends in
a Cain and Abel fashion according to old
man
she says the night's king was named
Brandon Stark and when he met this
sorceress that was pale as a corpse they
started making sacrifices to the others
which means the babies that were given
to the others beyond the wall had Starks
blood so some of these White Walkers
might actually be bastard stark children
at the time the night's king's brother
was the king in the north
the king of winter who also happened to
be a stark when he found out what his
brother was doing at the wall this
really pissed him off this pissed him
off so bad he was even willing to make
an alliance with the
king-beyond-the-wall who was known as
German and together they ended the
night's king and Queens reign over the
wall knowing the night's king was giving
sacrifices to the others this led the
king in the north to obliterating his
name from memory all records of him were
destroyed but I am hoping this new
series will be able to cover some of
this time period that way we can get
some more answers and hopefully find out
the truth behind the legend of the 13th
Lord Commander of the Nights Watch we
are also going to learn more about the
Starks of legend and I'm hoping we can
find out more about how they are
directly linked to the White Walkers the
night's king was most likely a stark but
I think there is more to it than just
that I think everything about the Starks
is connected to the White Walkers and if
this is true we may find out the
horrifying secrets behind how this
happened I recently made a video about
how Starks ancestral Valyrian steel
sword ice and the name of their sword
dates all the way back to the Age of
Heroes which is exactly what time period
this show is going to cover their
Valyrian steel sword was several hundred
years old but the name itself was
thousands of years old they had been
naming their house sword ice ever since
the Age of Heroes and I think this is
another direct link to the White Walkers
and the long night Catelyn Stark
actually thinks about this in one of her
chapters as she is watching Ned clean
the sword under the heart tree we can
also find out why the Starks chose their
house words winter is coming and even
find out why their Castle was named
Winterfell I tend to believe it is all
tied into the events that
happened during the long night the
greatest castle of the north is
Winterfell the seat of the Starks since
the dawn age legend says that Brandon
the Builder razed Winterfell after the
generation long winter known as the long
night
to become the stronghold of his
descendents the kings of winter in my
opinion one of the most fascinating
things about Winterfell was what lies
below the ground the crypts of
Winterfell are larger than Winterfell
itself with the older Starks buried in
deeper and darker levels the lowest
level was said to be partially collapsed
and I would love to find out what was
put in there when Winterfell was
originally constructed since all of this
was made right after the long night
ended we could potentially see some of
this happen in the new series I know
most of us have been dying to know more
about the crypts of Winterfell and the
kings of winter who reside in them song
and story tell us that the Starks of
Winterfell have ruled large portions of
land beyond the neck for 8,000 years
styling themselves the kings of winter
it would be interesting to learn more
about some of these Starks of legend
because we could also see how they
acquired some of their magical abilities
like being able to warg into animals
there were chronicles found in the
archives of the Nights Watch at the
night for and they speak of the war of
sea dragon point wherein the Starks
brought down the war King and his
inhuman allies the children of the
forest after the war King was defeated
by the Starks they had his sons put to
the sword
along with his beasts and green seers
but the war Kings daughters were taken
as prizes by their conquerors so it
sounds like the Starks laid with some of
the war Kings daughters which is how
some of the future members of House
Stark had the ability to warg into
animals also the Starks feuding with the
Bolton's dates all the way back to the
Age of Heroes as well Jaime Lannister
once said during the Age of Heroes
the Bolton's used to Flay the Starks and
wear their skins as cloaks we know
Ramsay Bolton had Winterfell torched but
that wasn't the first time a Bolton had
done this King Royce Bolton had also
taken hand
wonderful the Starks and the Bolton's
have been killing each other for over
8,000 years of course there are some
other legendary figures from the Age of
Heroes that they could introduce that's
if any of these legends have any truth
to them one of these characters is known
as Sir artists Aaron who lived many
thousands of years ago during the Age of
Heroes and he is remembered in song and
story as the winged Knight he supposedly
rode upon a huge Falcon the same way a
Targaryen would ride upon a dragon it
has said that armies of eagles fought at
his command and to win the veil he flew
to the top of the Giants lands and slew
the Griffon king he counted giants
amongst his friends and what a woman of
the children of the forest though she
died giving birth to his son there are a
hundred other tales told of him but in
the world of Ice and Fire book it is
said that it is highly unlikely that
such a man ever existed like laying the
clever in the westerland's and Brandon
the Builder in the north the winged
tonight is made of legend not a
flesh-and-blood another one of these
legendary figures is known as Garth
greenhand
and his story is very interesting in its
own right he was the high king of the
first men and it was he who led them out
of the East and across the land bridge
to Westeros but other tales would have
us believe that he preceded the arrival
of the first men by thousands of years
making him not only the first man in
Westeros
but the only man in Westeros wandering
the land alone entreating what the
Giants and the children of the forest
some even say he was a god now what's
also interesting about Garth greenhand
is some of these legends say he is a
contemporary of Brandon the Builder
laying the clever and some of the other
colorful figures of the Age of Heroes
but in other legends it also says that
he is the ancestor to them all God or
man Garth greenhand fathered many
children in this new land on this all
the tales agree many of Garth's
offspring grew to be heroes kings and
great lords and their own right
founding mighty houses that endured 4000
of years even the heroes of other lands
and kingdoms are sometimes numbered
amongst the offspring of the green hand
Brandon the Builder was descended from
girth by way of Brandon of the bloody
blade these tales would have us believe
even land the clever was said to be a
bastard born to one of gars daughter's
florist the Fox but other tales would
say that laying the clever would only
pose as one of his descendants that way
he could get some of the inheritance
which does make some sense because land
the clever was known for doing [ __ ] like
this laying the clever is another
legendary figure from the Age of Heroes
the Lannisters are an old family tracing
their descent back to land the clever in
the songs land was the fellow who
tricked the castor leaves out of
Casterly Rock with no weapon but his
wits in stole gold from the Sun to
brighten his curly hair
the last tale has certain intriguing
aspects that might hint at the truth of
what actually occurred
it is arts maester Parris tans belief
that land the clever was a retainer of
some sort in service to Lord castor Lee
perhaps a household guard who might have
impregnated his Lordships daughter or
daughters though that seems less likely
and persuaded her father to give him the
girl's hand in marriage if indeed this
was what occurred assuming as we must
that Lord castor Lee had no trueborn
sons than in the natural course of
events in the rock would have passed to
the daughter and hence to land upon the
father's death there is no more
historical evidence for this than any of
the other versions all that is known as
for certain is that sometime during the
Age of Heroes the castor Lee's vanished
from the Chronicles and the unknown
Lannisters appear in their place laying
the clever supposedly lived to the age
of three hundred and twelve in sired a
hundred bold sons and a hundred
daughters so as you can see the Age of
Heroes has a very rich history of its
own and I barely scratched the surface
in this video but I just wanted to go
over some of the events and colorful
figures from this time period because we
might get to learn more about them and
their true stories in the upcoming
prequel to
groans I don't know about you but I am
very excited about this because there is
a lot of potential here let me know what
you think and please feel free to
correct me if I got any other details
wrong but I did my best to pull directly
from the books that way I could be as
accurate as possible anyways I want to
thank you all for watching today's video
I really appreciate that and I also want
to thank everyone on patreon for
continuing to support the channel I hope
you all have a great day I will see you
again very soon bye
[Music]
[Music]